RETO MEIER: Google Cloud Next
2017 has hosted a lot of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch Rob Craft's introduction
to machine learning,
then stay tuned,
because here is the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: Eric
Schmidt describes
machine learning as the next
transformation of technology.
RETO MEIER: The programming
paradigm is changing.
Instead of programming
a computer,
you teach a computer
to learn something,
and it does what you want.
That's important, because
90% of the world's data
is unstructured.
It doesn't say,
hey, I'm a picture
of Reto's cat on a cat shelf.
We just have a picture.
It turns out that most
people on the internet
don't usually label things
with what they actually are.
So our challenge is to
drive unstructured data
into structured understanding.
Once you've got
structured data, you
can provide value on top of it.
COLT MCANLIS: In
order to achieve
that, you need a few
important things,
like good quality, clean
data, which is really hard.
75% of the workload for machine
learning data scientists
is doing data modeling
to get that clean data.
The remaining effort
is in algorithms
to apply to that data.
The machine learning
process takes
in data that comes in and
applies an algorithm against it
to generate predictions
that connect
the rest of your
business processes.
Now, chances are that the
algorithm isn't quite right,
or the data wasn't clean enough,
or you don't have enough data.
You will turn these, uh,
weird scenarios into something
that you operationalize
using specialists
focusing on data cleansing
and different algorithm types.
RETO MEIER: And for
some of these things,
you don't really need to
stay on the cutting edge.
You can use someone
else's black boxes
and focus your own team
on specialized systems
where you've got unique
IP to lend against it.
In practice, Google offers
tools across the spectrum
to help you.
Firstly, there's TensorFlow--
powerful, flexible, open source
set of frameworks that
allow you to create
your own set of systems with
exactly the same code that we
use internally.
The bad news is that it still
requires you to write the ML
equivalent of machine code.
Now, TensorFlow is largely
meant to advance the science,
but it also in many
cases is completely
sufficient for production use.
COLT MCANLIS: Next
is Cloud ML Engine.
This automates the most
painful parts of TensorFlow.
You can let us decide
if you need 64 GPUs
and if you need 12 of those
in the US or 14 in Asia,
how many SSD I/O ops per second
you need, and the how long
you'll likely need it.
We currently support T-shirt
sizing your environment
in small, medium, and
large, which means,
I want it eventually, or
it's a trivial problem;
or it's a reasonable problem,
and I want it reasonably
quickly and I'm
willing to pay for it;
or I really want
it now, and I don't
care how hard the problem is.
RETO MEIER: Finally, there
is the black box section
with pre-trained models for
translation, vision, and video.
But in the near
future, we expect
to have a solution that slots
in here between the final two
options, where you
can add the capability
to identify something specific
using your own data set.
And this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
If you'd like more
details on that,
you should check
out the full video.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget, the next
world tour coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]